si monsieur caire la parole monsieur le
ministre de l'économie en mars 2013 à
grand renfort de communication
le président de la république françois
hollande annoncé un choc de
simplification pour les particuliers les
entreprises
quatre ans plus tard l'heure est au
bilan
à bien des égards la montagne semble
avoir accouché d'une souris
il y a comme souvent avec ce
gouvernement un vrai décalage entre les
paroles et les réalités vécues au
quotidien par le concitoyen
pour les particuliers la simplification
n'est souvent qu'une apparence oui la
feuille de paye va par exemple être
simplifiées mais au lieu de simplement
masquer certaines lignes nantes il m'a
pas mieux valu pour les salariés les
entreprises alléger le coût du travail
mieux certaines nouvelles mesures anti
simplification vont très bientôt faire
leur apparition pour dans le quotidien
des français comme le prélèvement à la
source ou pour certains le permis de
louer pour les entreprises aussi le
bilan est très mitigé
de nombreuses mesures ont été prises
mais elles sont souvent contrecarrée par
la norme en place de nouvelles mesures
encore plus complexes comme la mise en
oeuvre de la déclaration sociale
nominative pour les pme la coller de
l'impôt à la source ou le conte
pénibilité merveilleuse usine à gaz
unique au monde qui restera des traces
tout cela est un peu à l'image du
principe silence de l'administration vos
accords que j'ai déjà été dans cet
hémicycle sur 3600 procédure
potentiellement concernés par ce
principe de simplification vous avez
prévu près de 1200 exception soit un
tiers
cet exemple est à l'image de votre choc
de simplification décevant et vidé de sa
substance
en résumé en matière de simplification
vous avez c'est d'agir sur le stock tout
en ne cessant dans le même temps de
créer de nouvelles normes
monsieur le ministre qu'est ce qui selon
vous n'a pas fonctionné
mais si la parole est à monsieur jean
vincent placé secrétaire d'état chargé
de la réforme de l'état et de la
simplification
que vous allez écouter en silencieux le
président mesdames et messieurs député
monsieur le député lionel tardy j'allais
commencer mon propos disant merci pour
votre question plus équilibré que votre
collègue ygos tournis qui m'a posé la
question ya deux semaines et je vais
être obligé de changer ma version
en vérité elle est extrêmement
caricaturale nous avons depuis trois ans
simplifier suite à la décision du
président de la république françois
hollande de lancer le choc de
simplification je ne vais pas remonter
aux états généraux de 314 pour dire que
notre administration est énormément
complexifier vous-même depuis 1993
j'avais été plus au pouvoir que nous
jamais vous n'avez simplifiée nous nous
avons choisi la réforme progressive
n'ont pas choisi la révolution ne
l'avons pas choisir les grands discours
comme ceux que vous tenez aujourd'hui
nous avons choisi une méthode la
concertation avec les partenaires
économiques et sociaux
le travail avec le conseil de
simplification de la vie des entreprises
nous avons choisi l'expérimentation avec
france expérimentation lancée il ya six
mois avec emmanuel macron relayé
aujourd'hui par christophe sirugue
je savais que ça allait vous animez et
nous continuons avec l'évaluation des
politiques publiques et marisol touraine
elle a mis en place la déclaration
sociale nominative qui fusionne une
vingtaine de mesures sociales
vous n'y avez jamais pensé hertz en y
ont dit que ça fait 3,7 milliards
d'économies nous avons annoncé plus de 6
ans mesure 5 milliards d'économies pour
les entreprises chaque année marchés
publics simplifiée différents
dispositifs simplification oui nous
allons plus vite plus clair plus simple
plus lisible dur rapide et je vais vous
dire votre question paraissait
intelligente mais face au pessimisme de
l'intelligence
nous avons choisi l'optimisme de la
volonté je vous remercie
merci monsieur placer la parole étant